[Music]
on today's show we're gonna talk to a
wonderful young mom
who's got three kids under three and
who's just decided to stay home
and she's trying to find a new identity
we're gonna talk to a young man
whose father was just diagnosed with
cancer and he's coming to terms with the
thought that he might lose his dad
and we're going to talk to a millionaire
who's trying to navigate family dynamics
and gift giving during christmas stay
tuned
[Applause]
hey what up what up this is john and
this is the dr john dolone show it's a
live
show for you about you and by you
where we walk alongside one another
trying to figure out the next
crooked wobbly step learning how to be
human beings
again and we talk about everything on
the show
anything and everything no matter what's
going on in your heart in your mind and
your family
i cannot even tell you how many millions
of people
are going through things just like you
and how many millions of people across
the country feel
alone how many millions of people across
the world
feel so alone i'm the only one who
thinks like this i'm the only one
who is stuck in this situation and you
are not
we are all in this together we're all
working through similar challenges
and this show is for you and on this
show i'm going to tell you the truth i'm
going to tell you the truth
we're going to get through these things
together we're going to figure out the
next right step
and we're also going to highlight what's
going right
in the world i got this email from
bessie
amaya in massachusetts
she writes hello dr dalony i wanted to
send you something positive
shout out bessie she was not my
elementary school teacher
but my high school anatomy and
physiology teacher at south high
community school
in massachusetts she made studying the
body so interesting and exciting
i fell in love with the dynamics of the
human body that seed was always there
and when i changed my major from
pharmacy
to nursing it just kept growing thanks
to
her implanting that seed i am now an
emergency room
nurse even though i'm obviously
overwhelmed due to the current pandemic
i can truly say i love what i do
i went to a community college as a
married adult with not just two kids but
one of them was just
one years old way to go bessie i was
also working part-time at a
nursing home while in school furthermore
even though it's
just a two-year associate's nursing
degree i've worked hard to get in a
position
where i make over 50 bucks an hour
to think it all started with that seed
that
dr laughlin planted it's grown and will
continue to grow to the tallest tree
so much that i'll be able to change my
family tree forever
with my current jobs organization
benefit of tuition reimbursement
i'm cash flowing my upcoming schooling
to get my bachelor's degree in nursing
shout out dr laughlin to every teacher
out there listening to this
every community college professor
every teacher who's a professor who's
trying to figure out
zoom and in person and in person and
zoom and
meeting on front porches so we can have
human contact but we can't be too close
and responding to emails and responding
to emails and
whatever it is you're trying to make
work remember you are planting seeds
like the seed dr
laughlin planted with bessie that will
grow
into new careers new dreams helping
people helping the least of these in the
middle of a pandemic
you never know what difference you are
making
dr laughlin in massachusetts thank you
thank you thank you for injecting joy
and positivity into the world
keep doing what you're doing thank you
bessie for sending in the note
for everybody out there making a
positive difference in your communities
and in your homes
and in your own hearts in your own heads
thank you
give me a shout if i can help go to
johndaloni.com
show fill out the form and we will check
it out we got a team of people here
reviewing
the bajillions of of requests that we
get
we'll see if they work for the show and
we will be in touch with you or you can
give me a call and leave a voicemail
1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
let's go straight to the phones let's go
to
hannah in mercado minnesota hannah how
are we doing
uh good how are you so good so good all
right
walk me through what's going on how can
i help
so i'm a new stay-at-home mom i just
started staying home in march do the
pandemic and then just stay at home
um and we're just beginning our journey
with the baby steps like we're just
planning everything out and i'm kind of
feeling like
i'm failing my husband a little bit not
bringing in an income and helping break
down our debt
gotcha all right so walk me through a
few things number one
how long have you all been married um
it'll be five years in january
five years and how long does jail date
before that
uh about a year and a half before we got
married
okay all right so six and a half years
you've known this dude right
yeah he's a good guy yeah he's a really
good guy
do you hear how your voice changed it
was like i'm failing him i'm terrible
yeah he's a really good guest so good
for you okay so and how many kids do you
have
uh three three how old are they
my oldest is two and a half and then i
have five month old twins
oh my so you are in it in it in it right
yeah okay and when did you
you decided to stop working in march
what was your career what were you doing
before then
i work in a daycare okay so you are all
about taking care of little ones huh
yeah so we knew i was going to stay home
when i had the twins it just got pushed
a little ahead because i was high risk
pandemic and stuff and because you were
growing two humans at the same time
yeah and it's just we couldn't make it
work with daycare very cool
all right so for those listening that
don't know the baby steps
i work for dave ramsey the get out of
debt
guy the guy that is preaches hope and
financial security
not being in debt not being slave to the
lender and
one of his programs is the baby step
programs
and step one is to get a thousand dollar
emergency fund
so if you do have an emergency or more
likely when you when you have an
emergency
you borrow money from yourself not from
some credit card company or some bank
that does not have your best interest in
mind
and they are trying to make a buck off
your misfortune
the second step is what he calls
gazelle intensity pay off all of your
debt smallest to largest
so hannah you find yourself with three
kids
still a relatively new marriage
you've transitioned out of full-time
work
and you're staying at home and you're in
baby step two how much debt are you guys
trying to pay off
i think it's like sixty thousand okay
what's your husband do for a living he
works construction
oh so he's grinding it huh yeah he's
gone
before we wake up till sometimes the
kids are in bed when he comes home
but he's making it happen it is not fun
to work outside
in construction in minnesota is it
no it's cold wow what a stud
all right so what's your household
income
um i think around 60 or 70. okay
so here's all that's all the context i
need
here's a couple of thoughts i want you
to keep in your heart and mind over the
next
few months and few years okay
getting out of debt is a really
important goal
in fact it's a critical goal it's one
that transformed my family it
transformed the peace in my soul
it transformed my family tree
when my kids see credit card ads they
all boo it's hilarious
so it's a good thing right now
you have two goals i want to put ahead
of that
goal number one is your young marriage
you've got a husband that is absolutely
kicking butt he is working hard
dark till dark cold cold cold
minus temperatures right
and you have three young kids
three tiny kids and that would be tough
for any marriage in any situation
and then the second thing is i want you
to focus on the goal
of being present with those kids
and so we live in a culture where
identity is based on achievement and it
used to just be boys
were given that but women have absorbed
that too
you are only worth what you achieve you
are only worth what you make
financially what's in the checking
account
and what we've got now is a generation
of men and women who
if they take a pay cut if they lose
their job
if they make a decision which i think is
an
honorable and noble decision to leave
the workforce and be present with
three young children right three kids
under three
yep then suddenly you look in the mirror
and think i'm not worth much
or what am i actually contributing or
i'm a drain on this family
and i need you to hear me as say it as
as boldly as i can
that's an absolute lie
you are a gift to your husband you are a
gift to those little kids
they need you fully present with them
and you are doing something much more
valuable than earning a paycheck
and you are giving three young babies
their their mother's full focus what a
gift
and so transitioning out of this this
consumer mindset
this i'm only worth my paycheck mindset
is going to require you to grab hold of
a new identity
and most of us myself included have not
done the hard work to figure out
who we are i've been working on it for
about a decade i'm getting closer
my wife experienced this she went from
dr deloney she was a professor
in a rock star she was a teacher before
that
and then she chose to stay at home and
it was tough as she made that transition
to
who am i now right and every woman's got
to go on that journey for themselves
well i strongly recommend that you
surround yourself
with women who are ahead of you in this
journey who are stay-at-home moms
themselves
who have been there who know the ups and
downs
i also want you to surround yourself
with women who are going to be really
graceful with you because you've got
three kids under
three in any circumstance in
any part of the world in any stage a
hurricane has hit your house it's a
joyful one
but it's also one with lots of diapers
lots of cha-cha lots of mommy mommy
mommy
lots of like your body is utilitarian
right now it's not even yours
and your husband is out grinding it and
grinding it
and it's hard to say hey i need some of
you too
because you know you don't want to be an
imposition on him you've got to learn
how to let your voice be heard in your
home
but most importantly you're going to
have to craft in some cases from the
floor up
a new identity and it might be the ceo
of the home it might be
i run this place he goes and earns a
paycheck
but i'm making it happen it might be i
am a full-time mom it might be
i'm a mom in this season and then i'm
going to go back and i'm going to own my
own daycare center
or i don't want to do that but my kids
are going to go to the daycare center
where i work whatever that happens to be
but your identity is somebody in
addition to work
it's something that holds up work we
were made to work we were made to love
our identity is deep our identity is
deeper than a paycheck deeper than a job
so hannah on 20 different fronts i
salute you
i salute you for making the hard
decision to stay at home i'm proud of
you for that
i salute you for being an absolute ninja
for taking care of three kids not taking
care of for raising
loving three kids under three i honor
you for
being a great wife and loving that
rugged outdoor construction husband
who's out there working dark to dark and
sub
freezing temperatures i salute you for
all of it
so i want you to get some people in your
corner and go craft an identity from the
floor up
and any time it seeps into your mind i'm
just a drain on this family
remember me saying that's a lie
i don't know where that's coming from i
don't know if it's from your mom from
your dad
from whatever social media accounts you
follow wherever that comes from
it's a lie you're worth everything
to that husband you are worth everything
to those kids and you're worth
everything to everyone listening to this
show i'm so grateful you're in the
communities that my kids are going to be
growing up in hannah
and now it's time to go do the fun hard
gut-wrenching work
of finding out who you really are and
who you're going to continue to grow
and become it's awesome hannah it's
awesome all right let's go to dan
in cedar rapids iowa dan the man what's
up
hi john thanks for taking my call um
really looking forward to
to talking with you a little nervous
also
hey i'm nervous too man i get nervous
all the time so it's all good so how can
i help brother
so a couple weeks ago my dad was
diagnosed with
liver cancer oh hold on hold on stop
what's up
can we just say that sucks yeah
have you sat down and just looked in the
mirror and looked in your own eyeballs
and just said
this sucks yes
yes and no um it just seems like i'm
taking
the diagnosis a little harder than than
my dad is
um growing up in a farming family you
were
conditioned to to show not show your
emotions
did you say a fireman family uh a
farming family farming family okay
farming family
yep and it just seems like yeah you
weren't supposed to
to show your emotions and and now it
just seems like it's
it's all coming out for me and um taking
over
taking over my life it seems like sure
so how old are you man
so 28 28 are you married you got kids
yup well i just recently married
um got married back in in august so uh
no kids as of right now yet but um
they're on their way or that's
that's in the the coming future very
cool so tell me about your old man
so yeah he's 74 years old
he's one of those guys that that that
everyone likes a heart of gold
hard worker
just just an all-around good guy it's
awesome
he's a good dad to you yeah yeah
we we talk on the phone probably
multiple times a day um
y'all did before the diagnosis what's
that y'all talked
you all talk that often before the
diagnosis
oh yeah yeah america listen
talk to your kids a couple of times a
day
cop talk to your kids a couple of times
a week good for you man
good for you and your dad yeah so it it
doesn't seem like we're trying to make
up for lost time
sure but it's all right this is what
we're facing
and all right what are we going to do to
go forward
yeah this yeah the cancer diagnosis it
doesn't phase him
at all even though that
he knows that it's it's on his liver and
potentially throughout the rest of his
body hey let me let me tell you a secret
about dads it absolutely phases him
it absolutely terrifies him
it absolutely breaks his heart
okay don't for one second let that iowa
farmer
the guy that just puts on his car hearts
and his overalls and gets back in the
tractor every day
don't let that stoic face trick you
he's already thinking about how much
he's going to miss you how much he's
going to miss his wife
he's hoping he gets to see a grandkid
trust me
it's it's it does faze him okay
and the reason that's important for you
to know is because right now you
probably feel crazy don't you
because he's just plugging along as
though it's another wednesday as though
it's another friday as though it's
another sunday and you just want to
scream out dude you've got cancer
right
is that fair yeah yeah no that's fair
and
so trust me when i tell you it faithes
him
now he may be a little more clinical
about it farmers deal with death their
whole lives
right and so there is something somewhat
poetic about it and beautiful about it
and routine about it
but it phases him okay so how are you
feeling man
all over the place um
yeah all over the place it's so i also
work off the farm as well and
it's it's one of those things that's
always on the front of your mind
you can't google the symptoms or
google liver cancer and and see the
prognosis
um sure yeah we're kind of
kind of all over the place um but
well actually right now he's he's having
a a biopsy and so he's
we're waiting to to find out what kind
of cancer
it is to start in the liver or did it
move to the liver so we're just kind of
all up in the air and
whether it's a really rough prognosis
or whether it is a cheerful
best case scenario
your dad still loves you and you still
love your dad
right oh absolutely and whether you've
got
six months left with them or 16 years
left with them
that won't change what will change
is whether you want to lean into those
last few moments
and love him recklessly
leave nothing unsaid no hug ungiven
or whether you want to lean into the the
remaining time
again whether it's 16 years or six
months
you want to lean into that time
cautiously as though he's fragile
as though you don't want to say the
wrong thing or hug
too tightly or or
what you have here man is something that
very few people have anymore
and that is a ironclad deep-rooted
relationship
between a father and a son where they
talk to one another
it's not imaginary it's not pretend
you all do hard work together outside
with your hands
and so make no mistake when he passes
away one day which he will it's going to
be
hard and it's going to be difficult
and he's also going to have raised you
to be strong
and resilient and heartbroken
and strong and resilient and sad
and all those things together again and
again and over and over
right
and so if you could say anything to your
old man right now he was sitting across
from you
and we we taped his mouth shut so he
couldn't
go oh oh oh so he couldn't say anything
what would you tell him oh
that's like
thank you for thank you for being there
and being good dad
i can think of few things in the world
few things in the world i'd rather hear
than my son look me in the eye and say
hey
you you're a good dad and he'd probably
rip that tape off and say i don't know
what you're talking about the worst
stuff i still am a good dad right
yeah yeah
so here's what's coming for you
a lot of feelings all of which are valid
not all of which are true
okay okay you're going to feel all
kinds of things you're going to range
from frustrated that he's not going to
do his will the right way
or he's going to have some ideas about
selling this tractor before
whatever you're going to have all these
kind of nuts and bolts things they're
going to drive you batty
some of that will be because he's it's
his and he can do what he wants some of
that's just going to be because you're
struggling with grief
you probably didn't get a great model
for what
uh grieving looks like
you probably didn't get a great model
for what vulnerability and feelings look
like
and so i want you to lean heavily into
your new marriage
and i want you to tonight tell your wife
i'm gonna start practicing something
i've never done before
and that is i'm gonna tell you how i
feel
and it's not always true and it's not
always correct but i'm just gonna
practice doing this and she'll say okay
great and then it's going to be
weird for both of you because she
married an iowa farmer knowing what she
got right and so this you're changing
the game for everybody
right but something you could give to
your children
something you could give to your wife is
something that few of us
know how to do which is be vulnerable
and be honest
sit in our feelings but don't bathe in
them right they don't become us
but we experience them and then we move
on because they lie to us they're not
always truthful
and then you can go be fully present
with your dad not speaking of him in the
past tense
but sitting right there with him when he
gets whatever diagnosis he's gonna get
yeah right is your mom still around
oh yeah yeah yeah mom's still around
luckily mom just retired back in
beginning of october so she can go
through this this entire process
with him um and it's a little different
with with covid because you can't
can't go and see him um because you
don't want him to
be battling be battling two fronts
that's right
so i want you to make a plan
for this weekend and i want you
to write your dad a letter that tells
him what he's meant to you
and i want this to be before the
diagnosis comes out
and that way you're not writing him a
good-bye letter
you're not writing him a praise god
letter
you're just writing him a letter between
father and son
it just says thank you so much for being
my dad
you did a great job and here's the thing
over the next few months regardless of
what happens that letter's gonna turn
into gold for him
he'll go back to it he'll go back to it
and he'll go back to it
and then as the weeks and months
progress
i want you to be direct with them how
are you feeling today
how's the chemotherapy going
how's my old man doing are you scared
i'm scared
hey new wife i woke up today and i was
scared
for my dad i was scared about the future
of the farm
can we just hug for a minute
and i want you to start making a list of
things maybe ask your dad hey what are
some things you did intentionally with
me that i can pass on to my
young son to my young daughter and let
your dad
verbalize let him teach you at all we
all
love being the one who gives advice and
gives wisdom feels good people call you
and ask you
but cherish every moment let no hug go
unhugged
let no words go unsaid
you were given one of the greatest gifts
a person could ever get
which is a lovely present father
good for you what a blessing we'll be
thinking about you during this time i do
want you to shoot me a note back
about what the diagnosis is what the
prognosis is
and then keep checking back in with us
and we'll continue to tell your story on
the air because
you're a gift dan your dad's a gift and
we want to honor him in his upcoming
months and hopefully upcoming years
thank you so much for the call all right
let's take one more let's go to jeremy
in atlanta georgia jeremy what's up
brother
hey dr d thanks for taking my call i'm
big fan of
you and the whole ramsey team thank you
so much man how can i help today
well i heard you answer a boundaries
question the other day
and i wanted your take on our situation
my wife and i
got an email from my brother's wife in
february saying that they were not able
to buy
christmas gifts this year so that they
and they'd like not to receive any from
the rest of the family as well because
of that
and my wife and i are in baby step seven
in a position to bless them
and we'd like to do that so is it
inappropriate of us to go
and get them gifts
i think it would be inappropriate to do
that
just up and do it um
if i was in your situation i would
respond to that email
and say thank you so much for letting us
know about your situation
it's been a hard year we're praying for
you let us know we can help
that that honors his honor your
sister-in-law right your brother's wife
right right and then i'd call my brother
and say look
brother to brother here's the situation
i'm in
i would love to bless you guys this year
no strings attached no special this is
and that's
i just had a good year and
honor him in that way if you think he
can hear it
do you think he can hear it or is he
going to roll his eyes and be like
where's my brother trying to get in my
junk again
is you know what i mean i think my
brother would hear it but his wife
maybe would have a different so he might
agree to it and then
later she would regret that he did
that's between her and him not you okay
do you have a relationship with her you
all have a good relationship
well it's been strained over the years
as we've had kids and they were not able
to and
so it's it's been up and down
she's opted out of some family
gatherings
when we've gotten together sure
so the hard thing for you is she's
allowed to do that she's a grown-up
and you're a grown up and so
i wouldn't take it personally you've had
a lot of wins you've had kids you're a
millionaire
they haven't they've had different
financial situations they've not had
been able to have kids there's all kinds
of
dynamics at play here right right
so when it comes down to it
honor her wishes man i do think it's
worth calling your brother i do think
it's worth leaning into him and saying
hey man how can i help and it's his
responsibility to manage his
relationship with his wife if he thinks
that's going to get them too in trouble
and all that
great i also think
this is a great year to not do christmas
presents as a family
to buy each other one cd of
your favorite music to buy each other
one book that's impacted you in the past
year
to buy each other one hilarious coffee
mug or one hilarious shirt
the temptation this year is going to be
to
spend your way out of this funk
to try to compensate for the kids lost
graduations and loss school events
and lost little league seasons and lost
business opportunities by trying to buy
people happiness back and good folks it
does
not work like that now jeremy you're in
a different situation man you're
a millionaire for those of you who don't
know i work for dave ramsey
baby step seven is the pinnacle that's
when you can live like no one else
and more importantly give like no one
else
you can give obnoxiously generously
somewhat recklessly
but sometimes your gift is somebody
else's burden
sometimes somebody else doesn't want
that gift and if she drew a boundary
you got to respect it that's the
honorable thing to do even if you think
you know better than that boundary
so call your brother lean into that but
good folks
every year this same thing happens
christmas just up and surprises us
it surprises us emotionally it surprises
us financially
it surprises us spiritually right
so here's a couple of things i think
i think that every year
i don't know for a thousand years couple
thousand years
again i'm making that up there's gonna
be some calendar expert who's gonna
write into the show
go for it it's gonna make you feel good
and i'll learn something so i say
write in write in with vigor it's
probably wikipedia for crying out loud
but christmas is on december 25th it
just is in the united states christmas
is on december 25th
same time every year
and so it shouldn't surprise you it
shouldn't sneak up on you and blow
your mind you can save a hundred bucks a
year
i mean i'm sorry a hundred bucks a month
and have one thousand
two hundred dollars to spend at
christmas you can spend
50 bucks or you can save 50 bucks a
month over the course of a year and have
600
to spend on christmas whatever it looks
like it doesn't sneak up on you
when it comes to the emotional side of
the relational iq
side who are you going to buy presents
for where are you going to go
what year is it to go to which family
in this season of a pandemic can we
travel
when you know to somebody's house where
they're going to have different
government restrictions or somebody else
who's going to be high risk
or do i work in a job where i might have
coven take it to people all those things
are conversation you should be having
right now today
today and if there was ever a year to do
something different
this is the one if there's
ever a year to say you know what we just
keep upping the ante with how many
christmas presents we buy we keep
upping the ante for how extravagant
christmas gets
done stop this is the year of the reset
this is the year when we say you know
what kids we're each going to get each
other two things
three things and then we're gonna go for
a long christmas walk
we're gonna all cook together we're
going to do things
not related to an xbox
not related to a screen we're gonna just
be together we're gonna figure out how
to play games
my kids this morning and last night but
this morning when i woke up i woke up to
the sounds of them
jabbing at each other and cheering and
talking trash
they've taken that old school game clue
which a game they don't have any idea
how to play
and created a new kid game version that
really doesn't make a lot of sense
um it's like playing with drunk college
kids
it's not a lot of like rational thought
but the idea is awesome and we sat down
for a game
and it's all great and good and when
everybody loses to the four-year-old
it's hilarious and
but man they are making memories they
are using creativity and they are having
a lot of fun
and they are have developed some sort of
weird game where
the rope beats the pipe and the pipe
beats the
whatever the candlestick and so on and
so forth and now my four-year-old's
like the power hungry mogul in the house
right now
but all that to say decide to have
experiences decide to have engagement
with one another decide to look each
other in the eye
and i also believe this with all of my
heart if you know i'm going to visit
uncle eddie you know we're going to
visit grandma and grandpa
and this is just who they are they are
loud they always
get us crappy food they get frustrated
with us
they never like the gifts we buy and you
choose to still go
you forfeit the right to throw a fit
when you're there
because you knew if you
get there and suddenly you're like my
parents are just doing this again
you knew you knew and so at that point
you are choosing
to feel bad you're choosing you're
making a
stone cold decision to have a less than
experience
don't do that don't do that
go into it and make the best of it go
into it with a smile
go into it like jeremy just wants to
bless people good for you man
if it's not going to be your brother and
your wife so be it
find other people to bless i know you
will because that's your heart
and if somebody wants to bless you and
you've had a really humble
crappy year let them bless you
this isn't the year for ego this isn't
the year for being right this is the
year for saying thank you
i'm grateful for you man i'm really
grateful for you
christmas will be here on december 25th
prepare for it now
financially spiritually emotionally
what does the christmas season mean to
you
and just because they changed the color
of a coffee cup is not a political
statement everybody
everybody relax
let's make christmas peaceful let's make
christmas joyful let's make the holiday
season one that we want to look forward
to
and not drama and stress we're done with
drama and stress we've had enough
so that i could talk all day about gift
buying and boundaries
and christmas it's my favorite time of
the year
it's when all the leaves are off the
trees everything is stark and bare
and the world slows down we just all
have a little peace
all right so as we wrap up today's show
we're here to the song of the day
one of the greatest songs ever written
by a really awesome band
they are highly highly highly underrated
they're incredible
off their 1994 self-titled album
otherwise known as the blue album one of
my favorite bands of all time
weezer with their greatest song ever
that's actually not true they've got a
lot of great songs this is one of their
greatest songs
it's called buddy holly and they write
what's with these homies dis and my girl
why do they got a front
what did we ever do to these guys that
made them so violent
woo hoo but you know i'm yours woo hoo
and i know you're mine woohoo and that's
for
all of time ooey i look just like buddy
hailey
ooey you i look just like buddy holly oh
oh and you're mary tyler moore i don't
care what they say about us anyway
and i don't care about that i don't even
know what the song means
but it's incredible this has been the dr
john deloney show